one of the biggest things that holds
people back is they worry about what
other people will think what has been
your approach for negative comments or
haters that have come your way you know
when you just think about all the
successful people in the world right
they have haters people who don't have
success don't have haters like when I
see people so divided about LeBron it's
like how do you hate Leon like he's so
good it makes no sense that you don't
like him but people do dude to become
the president 50% of the the world has
to hate you I also think that you
shouldn't you know maybe be trying to
get people to hate you but you should be
saying things
that not everyone's going to agree with
like you cannot play both sides and
always be politically correct you know I
say things that piss a lot of people off
and I believe them